today's classic interview we are going
back to my interview in 2014 with George
Lake off George Lake office sort of the
master of political framing and I want
to think about whether what he says
about how Republicans have historically
been more successful at MIT winning the
framing game then Democrats in the
context of the 2016 election George Lake
off super smart and has really broken
down the ways in which Republican
language has been more effective at
controlling and framing the debate and
Democratic language I really look
forward to checking out this classic
interview and sort of thinking about it
in terms of Trump and Clinton let's take
a look it's great to be joined today by
George Lake off who is professor of
cognitive sciences and linguistics at
the University of California Berkeley
and author of the all-new don't think of
an elephant know your values and frame
the debate you know it's so great to
have you on your original book is such a
great resource in terms of framing and
messaging and how important language is
for progressives and also true to be
perfectly honest in pointing out some of
the failures of progressive messaging
what have you added or changed in this
new edition of the book Oh about 80% I
learned a lot in the last 10 years I've
seen a lot of not very good messaging
coming out of the Democratic Party I've
seen better than it was before which is
good I've seen a lot of mistakes being
made by our administration I've seen
progressives not understanding what they
need to be doing I've seen a lot of
things happening and I wrote about them
the idea was to bring everything up to
date and of course the issues are
different so it's about I would say it's
eighty percent new work and everything
else is rewritten and brought up to date
so some of the great examples that you
had in the original version that that
still stand out in my mind include your
discussion about taxes and how really
progressives have not done a good job of
showing how taxes really are an
investment taxes are patriotic those
who are not paying taxes in a sense are
essentially free riders they're getting
the stuff for free there the welfare
recipients so to speak that the
Republicans often criticized do you
still think that progressives are doing
a poor job on the issue of taxation a
terrible job and the there's a general
point that became clear after a while
conservatives and progressives have
totally different views of what
democracy means hmm for progressive
democracy is about citizens caring about
each other and working through their
government to provide public resources
for everybody that means everybody you
want to start a business you have sewers
you have roads bridges you have an
internet you have satellite
communication you have water you have
electricity if all these things that are
provided for by public resources the
educated people you have public health
you're not you know you know saddled
with disease etc you can then go and do
your business but all those things are
taken it for granted and not noticed and
they're crucial because that is what
public resources are about you can't
have a business work in a business or do
anything at all without public resources
and the same is true for private life
that is in private life you need health
you need to be able to be sure you have
safe foods safe drinking water clean air
you need to be able to know that there
are diseases spreading around you you
needed to have public safety or all
these things that are public resources
provided for you all the time you want
to take a drive you need to have roads I
mean this is crucial and um you know we
take those things for granted it's like
during the background they're just there
but they're not just there what taxes
are about and and i think the word tax
is not a very good work these are public
resources the crucial idea is that the
private depends on the public whether
its private
enterprise or private life in all cases
the private depends on the public and
without the public you don't have any of
those things and that takes some money
it means that you know that that you get
no matter how much you earn you're
getting a lot from other people from
your other fellow citizens you no matter
how much you're paying in taxes you
couldn't afford it to do all the things
that all the other citizens are doing
with you and for you well I'm curious
along these lines whether you would
agree that the Democratic messaging
around the Affordable Care Act has been
an absolute disaster particularly when
you take into consideration that when
polled fairly right not with loaded
questions or leading polls people for
the most part are way more progressive
than what the Affordable Care Act even
provides yet it has seemed to be still
one of the most controversial and
dividing issues amongst Americans this
issue of the Affordable Care Act has it
been a progressive framing and messaging
mistake or is there something else we
can link to why people just don't seem
to agree with the Affordable Care Act in
theory while they very much agree with
what it does it's a messaging disaster
before um the president came into office
after he was elected he had a poll done
on what provisions people would most
want and then in the Affordable Care Act
and all the provisions you know no
preconditions no capture your
college-age kid can be on your health
insurance and so on and so on lot lots
of provisions they were all 64 80%
approved of and they still are so people
like those provisions and today however
and one of the interesting things that
conservatives never attacked the
provisions you've never heard a
conservative stay there should be
preconditions you know pregnant women
shouldn't be allowed to get insurance or
you have cancer you shouldn't be allowed
to go to church nobody says that
never attack what they did do was they
understood that issues about the details
of health care are in one part of the
brain and this is a morality or another
and they went moral and they went moral
on two principles freedom and life so
they started attacking they said this is
a government takeover and there are
death panels government takeover death
panels government takeover death panels
over and over and over and then they
quoted Obamacare as if it weren't about
affordable could be affordable care act
as if it weren't about affordable care
they said this is really about Obama
government takeover death battles right
and they repeated it and repeated it and
the Obama administration didn't come
back and say look yes this is about
freedom in life you have cancer you
don't have health insurance you're not
free even break your leg you don't have
health insurance you can't get it said
you can't walk you're not free it's
about freedom health is always about
freedom and life you could die you have
cancer you don't have health insurance
you're going to die you know this is
about freedom and life the most
principled things you can imagine they
could have come back and completely
undercooked a conservative argument and
they didn't why do you think they didn't
because they don't understand how
framing works and they don't understand
it for a deep reason they went to
college now I'm not being cynical about
this if you are a conservative and you
go to college you're very likely to take
some business courses and in the
curriculum you'll take marketing and
marketing professor's study my field
cognitive science and what that means is
they understand that people think in
terms of framing metaphors images
emotions and narratives that's what
that's how it works and conservatives
are very good at marketing their ideas
on that basis they understand that that
is that is in fact rationality that is
what real rationality is about but if
you go to college in your den
Craig you want to go into politics
you're going to study political science
going to study public policy economics
law feels like that and they work on
what is called enlightenment reason from
the Year 1650 and that says all phone is
conscious when in fact it's ninety-eight
percent unconscious it says thought is
just logical it works by logic and what
its recent of rationality is what makes
us human all so we have all the same
reason so if you just tell people to
facts they should reason to the right
conclusion utterly false people think in
terms of first what is most deeply
important to them personally I'm among
that the moral system and what what they
consider right secondly they're not
necessarily if it be in terms of frames
because that's how everyone thinks
everyone thinks in terms of frames and
in politics all framing is moral that is
if you are a politician and you get come
up and you say look here's what I think
you should do here's the right policy we
need an affordable care act bah bah bah
ok the assumption is it's because it's
right not because it's wrong no
politician comes out and says do what I
do because it's wrong or it doesn't
matter the assumption is that it's right
and the difference in policy has to do a
difference in moral systems and we have
a moral system which I just mentioned
for progressives you know it is people
care about each other it's about empathy
it's about doing things together for
community for other people as well as
for yourself that is a crucial part of
progressive morality and it's crucial to
American democracy that's why we have
public resources now the Democrats get
up there and what they do is they just
recite the list of you know 24 policies
that go into this at one point the
Democrats you know send out a message on
their website to 13 million people it
said talk to all your friends and
neighbors of
what is wonderful about the Affordable
Care Act and here are the 24 things but
just to make it easier for you we put
them in three groups of eight nobody's
going to remember three groups of a any
cognitive scientists will tell you
nobody's going to remember three groups
of eight I've never met anyone who did
you heard that and did remember the
three groups of eight the point is that
they don't think that way they think in
terms of enlightenment reason just given
the facts and give them a long list
that's not how people think so no
question that as you've said before the
progressive mind set on framing and
messaging is not linking up with the
progressive morality so to speak exactly
that morality is unconscious and
automatic unconscious in the sense of it
isn't used it is used so much all the
time it doesn't have to be mentioned
it's not it's not that anything anybody
pays attention to because it's part of
who you are then yeah people don't
understand that that is what's crucial
about everything and it's about freedom
that is all those public resources give
you freedom they give you the freedom to
sort of business to work in a business
the freedom to live a decent life the
freedom to be healthy to freedom to be
educated those are freedoms and and
freedom is very important for a lot of
reasons just about every progressive
issue comes down in large measure and
not always in everything but in order to
measure to be a freedom issue take what
is the right wing talks about the
abortion issue you don't talk about the
abortion issue this is about a woman's
freedom to control her own body but it's
not just a woman's freedom it's
everyone's freedom to control their own
bodies absolutely no question about it
and we are of course speaking with
Professor George Lake off the book is
don't think of an elephant know your
values and frame the debate the all new
version of the book with eighty percent
new material really a pleasure having
you on thanks so much for joining us my
pleasure thank you David